we start in washington dc where it's
becoming increasingly clear that the
democratic party doesn't give a damn
about you you got americans becoming
increasingly concerned about education
their children inflation chaos of the
border and gas prices but what is
happening in washington democrats aren't
even listening or even pretending to it
doesn't look like their agenda matches
up to i don't know anybody's agenda
except theirs massachusetts rep for
example
ayanna presley is off this phone has
been sent to voicemail for the last 18
months and one of the things she says is
she listens to her constituents well i
hope her constituents haven't needed
anything for the last 18 months like i
don't know answers on why the grocery is
so expensive gas is double and a whole
lot more like the supply chain and
christmas instead presley's sites are
set on something entirely different
care is infrastructure housing is
infrastructure climate justice is
infrastructure paid leave is
infrastructure disability justice's
infrastructure let's pass the bill back
better act
all right uh you got the gist she
doesn't care what the people who
actually elected her have to say or if
they even have a road to drive to right
instead she's just following the lead of
aoc and the other squad members
progressives as they try to push through
this massive spending bill that reads
more like a progressive wish list which
they currently can't even approve
because there's not enough of their
wishes granted on that list which is
over 1600 pages it seems like the
government is doing everything possible
to make you dependent on them just look
at how the white house envisions your
life they have actually released this
comic it's called the life of linda now
it focuses on a single mom and a son
making forty thousand dollars a year and
shows the government can control them
from the cradle to grave let's show a
few of them and let's look at it
together it's really exciting all right
let's start here it's time because you
have a child tax credit to go shopping
now you can afford it with that 300 per
month after shopping i want you to drop
your son who's supposed to be three but
looks like he's 13 at preschool for some
high quality free pre-k care and then
let's take a look at free community
college guess what it yields you learn a
trade to get that union government job
where you build windmills that is indeed
the goal i don't know is that the
aspiration of every young woman to be a
single parent desperately trying to grab
hold of a government job this is the
same government that has no problem
taking your hard-earned dollars and
pledging it to people beyond our borders
it brings me to the next story case in
point wall street journal today the big
story i didn't even think it was true
the biden administration is in talks
right now to offer illegal immigrant
families that were separated during the
trump administration
450 000 maybe more in personal
compensation to resolve lawsuits filed
on behalf of parents and children who
the government subjected them to lasting
psychological trauma by separating them
at the border something that was
reversed by the president through an
executive order the president at the
time president trump you heard that
right
450 000 a person and migrants are
getting the news that you can cash in on
traveling with children that's going to
be a go sign for everybody else as the
ap reports the new caravan coming from
mexico
is full of children so forget making
windmills apparently all you have to do
in america to get rich is cross the
border alone and then sin for your
parents later think of that message it
sends to others in other countries as
tax dollars of hard-working americans
like you are going to be handed over to
legit criminals who flat out broke our
law senator tom cotton put it very well
in a quote on a tweet saying this pay a
burglar who broke into your home for the
psychological trauma they endured while
doing the crime remember they came to
our border illegally so how does this
end up who is advising the president
texas democrat congressman henry cuellar
broke it down on the radio with me today
remember democratic congressman from
texas listen
he has surrounded himself at least on
the immigration issue with people that
have backgrounds and
i'll call him immigration activist the
administration gets advice from career
people and from this political
appointees the career people in homeland
and other places they get it i talk to
them they get it but
you know you got political people that
make those type of decisions and it's
unfortunate that they're not listening
to the career people the men and women
in green and blue and other
folks that have been doing this for so
many years
so you understand that if you actually
want to solve the problem and you don't
want to deal with the republicans you
have a democrat who lives on the border
on a border state representing
democratic constituents who put him in
office every year he has the answer to
the border he goes to other countries
and he actually stays in his country and
then tries to get through to a
democratic president and he doesn't even
take his calls it's now open business
for illegals crossing hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now